>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Becky Brasington Clark:
Good evening and welcome.
>> Good evening.
>> Becky Brasington
Clark: Thank you for that.
Let's try that again.
Good evening and welcome.
>> Good evening.
>> Becky Brasington
Clark: Thank you.
My name is Becky Brasington
Clark and I have the privilege
of directing The Library of
Congress publishing office.
We're delighted to see this
crowd here, particularly
on such a beautiful day.
After such cold weather that you
actually chose to come inside
and stay inside for a
while is really a testament
to your conviction
in this program.
Tonight in celebration
of the 60th Anniversary
of National Library
Week, we're delighted
to welcome Dr. Kenneth Breisch,
author of American
Libraries 1730 to 1950.
Dr. Breisch's book is the latest
in the acclaimed Norton Library
of Congress Visual Source
Book in American Architecture,
Design, and Engineering series.
This series is a project of
the Center for architecture,
design and engineering in
The Library of Congress,
which was established
through a bequest
from a distinguished American
architect, Paul Rudolph,
to support the library's
preservation of collection items
in these fields and to
increase public knowledge
of and access to them.
Following Dr. Breisch's talk,
The Emeritus founding director
of the center, Ford
Petross (assumed spelling),
will say few words
about the architecture
of The Jefferson Building
and give you some insight
into what you're about to
see on the post lecture tour.
I want to thank, offer a few
thanks before introducing
Dr. Breisch.
First of all, Nancy
Green [assumed spelling],
the series editor
at W.W. Norton,
who worked on this series
for many, many years
and was a real inspiration
and driving force behind
the books in this series.
And she can't hear us,
because she's not here tonight,
but she knows how much we
appreciate her great work
on this series.
And also want to thank library
colleagues who came together
to make this evening possible,
especially Helena
Zincon [phonetic],
Mary Nakahara [phonetic],
Barbara Natenson [phonetic],
Ford Petross, Jamal
Forbes [assumed spelling],
Steve Hersch, Brett
Cronell [phonetic],
Katherine Blood [assumed
spelling],
Laura Chipchick [phonetic],
Mary Mundy, Melissa Lindbergh,
Donna Collins, Cheryl
Kennedy [assumed spelling],
Peggy Wagner, Susan
Rayburn, Amy Hess,
Hannah Friese [assumed
spelling],
Cheryl Lowe [assumed spelling],
and Sean Miller [assumed
spelling].
And I'm sure I"ve missed
a couple of people,
and for that I offer
groveling apologizes.
Finally it's a pleasure
to introduce our speaker,
Dr. Kenneth Breisch.
Dr. Breisch is an associate
professor in the School
of Architecture at
the University
of Southern California.
He's the former director
and founder
of USC's graduate program
in heritage conservation.
He has taught at CY ARK
[phonetic], the University
of Delaware, and the
University of Texas at Austin.
He is the author of
Henry Hobson Richardson
and the Small Public
Library in America
and the Los Angeles
Central Library,
Building an Architectural
Icon, 1872 through 1933.
We had the privilege of
chatting with Dr. Breisch
for a few minutes while he
was pre-signing the books,
which are available for
purchase in the back.
And we learned that he
has been kind of obsessed
with libraries for
many, many years.
And among Library of
Congress employees,
that's a great badge
of distinction.
So without further adieu,
Dr. Kenneth Breisch.
[ Applause ]
>> Kenneth Breisch:
Thanks, Becky.
The truth be told, I just like
hanging out with librarians.
Well, you've thanked many of
the people I was going to thank,
but I should repeat
at least briefly.
I want to thank you, Becky, and
Ford Petross and Helena Zincon
in the department of
prints and photographs,
Amy Hess in the publishing
office,
who did an amazing job tracking
down with her eagle eye the
details in terms of the URLs
for all of the illustrations
which you'll see in the book.
Nancy Green at Norton,
and then Daniel Greenberg
and Susan Steinhouser,
who actually helped
subsidize the book
with their foundation
in Los Angeles.
And so I'm very grateful
to them.
And then Katy Horack
[assumed spelling],
who was one of my
graduate students,
was a graduate student
many years ago
when the book was started, who
helped me get going on the book.
This lecture is going to be
very general and just a kind
of introduction, I think,
to what's in the book.
But also the book itself is
intended as an introduction
to illustrations
in the departments
of prints and photographs.
Or the division, I should
say, of prints and photographs
at The Library of Congress.
And so the images were chosen
from what they have
in their collections.
Hence, which is a
question I get often,
why the book ends in 1950.
They're now collecting
more images of post 1950
or post World War II buildings,
but there just were
not enough images
to really make an
argument for the history
of post World War II
library buildings.
Additionally, maybe
I should be grateful
that they didn't
have the images,
because as of now I think there
are almost 17,000 public library
buildings alone in
the United States.
That includes branch
libraries, large libraries.
And that's not including,
of course, college,
university libraries, et cetera.
So maybe, as I say,
I should be thankful
that I had an excuse not
to try to deal with that.
But they do have wonderful
resources, and that's one
of the purposes of the book.
They have the Carol
Highsmith collection.
She's the one who's filling
in now the post war images.
And you'll see some of
those at the end of my book,
beautiful color photographs.
The Detroit Publishing
Company Archives,
the Farm Security
Administration,
the Gottscho-Schleisner
Collection.
Theodor Horydczak,
I think collection,
if I'm pronouncing
that correctly.
And, of course, the Historical
American Building Survey
and many others that
I used as a source
of reference for this book.
I can't see exactly, but
that should be right, yes.
I'll trust that we're on
the right slides here.
It's especially a privilege,
I think, to be speaking
about libraries in The
Thomas Jefferson Building.
Thomas Jefferson, as you
know, believed fervently
in public education and
education as the foundation
for American Democracy.
And one of the primary focuses
of his philosophical program was
the founding of the University
of Virginia as a public
educational institution.
And the centerpiece
of that campus,
of that enlightenment inspired
campus, was the rotunda
or the library replacing
what actually in Europe
and the United States,
that's the early colleges,
had been the chapel.
So it reflects his, as I say,
enlightenment interests
in education.
Libraries of course extend far,
much further into the past than,
of course, Jefferson, back to
the legendary of course Library
of Alexandria 300 BC in the
Tolamase [phonetic] and then
up through the Middle Ages
in the next Kodex
Amiotus [phonetic],
which shows Ezra
writing the law.
This was published in
the late 16th Century,
as I think you can see.
I find it really fascinating
in that the fundamental
requirements
of the library have really
changed very little over time.
This could almost
be a computer carol,
except that there
are books there.
But you have to have ample
storage for your collections,
depending upon the size, a quiet
comfortable well lit hopefully
place to read or now to
access your computer,
although I still read.
And then as libraries became
larger, of course stations
or desks for the distribution of
books or the charging of books
for the distribution of
information to library patrons.
And then as we know at The
Library of Congress a variety,
a great variety of spaces
for administrative activities
sorting books, repairing books,
and just bureaucratic work
in many different ways.
So libraries can
really come in any kind
of size, shape, or form.
We have Roy's wonderful library.
Ansel Adams was commissioned
to document the internment camp
during World War II at Manzanar,
where there were 100,000
Japanese, or 10,000 at Manzanar,
but interned during the war.
Roy Tucano [phonetic]
actually was the editor
of the camp newspaper,
and this is his library
which you can imagine was
very, very precious to him.
And I find it fascinating
too, that while Ansel Adams,
a great American photographer,
was recording the architecture
in the camp that he zeroed in
on this small but, as I say,
very precious kind of
collection of books.
This, of course, is a private
collection and it's one
of a variety of different types
of libraries that are talked
about the in the book.
The Loganian Library, which
you can see here, I think,
is in a way a descendant
or related
to Benjamin Franklin's Library
Company of Philadelphia,
which he founded in 1731.
But James Logan's library
was a private collection,
probably the largest or nearly
the largest in the country
at the time numbering
some 2,600 volumes.
And he built this small
building to house it.
It's the first actually,
I think,
purpose built public library
or library building
in the United States.
He made his money
in the fur trade.
He was a close associate
of the Penn family,
one of the wealthiest
people in the country.
But he allowed scholars
and others into the library
to use the collection.
It's one, of course, of dozens
of private libraries
here in Washington.
The Folger-Shakespeare
Library, for example.
But the Morgan Library,
The Huntington Library
in Los Angeles, all of
which are private libraries
that housed collections that
were accumulated by individuals
who loved books and then for
the most part opened them
up to scholars and the public.
But these libraries, to me,
remind me often of a quote
in Alberto Manuel's book,
The Library at Night,
which if you don't know it,
you should, in which he writes
in the introduction, "No one's
stepping," and this could apply
to many, many libraries,
but especially these
research libraries, I think.
"No one's stepping for the
first time into a room made
of books can know
instinctively how to behave.
What is expected?
What is promised?
What is allowed?
One may be overcome by horror
at the clutter or the vastness,
the stillness, the
mocking reminder
of everything one doesn't
know, the surveillance.
And some of that overwhelming
feeling may cling on even
after the rituals and
conventions are learned,
the geography mapped, the
natives found friendly."
I feel that way about
my research often,
and the natives are always
found friendly eventually.
But it can be intimidating
certainly
to enter a foreign territory
and foreign libraries.
The book also has a chapter
on The Library of Congress.
We'll be fortunate
today to see parts of it
that I haven't seen actually and
that many people haven't seen.
But as you probably know,
I think you're all nadens
[phonetic] of the Library
of Congress, but it was
founded in 1800 by legislation,
by Congress, and then
burned in the War of 1812,
in 1814 actually, and owes
it resurgence in large part,
at that time, to Thomas
Jefferson again, who in 1815,
in debt as he often was,
sold his library of some five
or six thousand books.
Some of them have survived
to The Library of Congress.
There was grumbling on the
part of the Congressmen
as to why they would be spending
money, especially on books
that they couldn't read because
many were in Latin or Greek
or other, French even,
foreign languages.
Things don't change much,
I guess, in some ways.
But that forms the core
of a real research library
for Congress, the government,
but also other individuals.
Eventually in 1851, a
new structure was built
in the library to
house the books.
This is by Thomas Eustic Walter.
It was a fireproof
iron construction,
because there had been a second
fire just previous to this
in which many of Jefferson's
books actually were
unfortunately destroyed
as well as other books.
This served as The
Library of Congress really
up until it was replaced by this
building, which began actually
to be contemplated
in the early 1870s,
the proliferation of books.
And the Copyright Act, which
required books to be placed
in The Library of Congress,
meant that this small library
was very quickly outgrown
so that in 1873 Congress
authorized a competition
for the new Library of Congress.
Here you can see an entry
by Alexander Este actually
in the collection and
prints and photographs.
There are dozens and
dozens of these drawings.
This will have to
do for an exterior.
It's the late 19th Century.
You can imagine every eclectic
style was submitted by good
and not so good architects.
The idea though, was to model it
on the British Museum
Reading Room.
And most of the entries had a
rotunda or circular reading room
at the center of the collection.
This is by John Frazier.
These are just examples.
The next is a detail.
I think we're lucky we got what
we got, and not this perhaps,
but this was his proposal
for the reading room
which ultimately as designed by
Smith, Myer and Pelts beginning
with their final designs.
They actually entered the
early competition in 1888,
resulted in the reading
room that we have today
that you're all familiar with.
But it really only forms a
central focus of the library.
Something we'll see today are
the stacks that open up around
that library, stacks there
were designed to hold millions
of books, one of the largest
libraries at the time.
And also a very modern library
with equipment designed
by Bernard Green.
Conveyor belts, pneumatic tubes
to convey orders from patrons
to librarians in the
shelves or in the stacks,
and then they would be
loaded onto conveyors
and delivered back
to the delivery room.
So I find that interesting
as well, when we talk
about modern technology
in the library,
that it's really not all
that new to some extent,
although they didn't have
computers certainly at the time.
There are other types
of libraries
that form their own
chapters in the books.
Society Libraries.
These were private libraries
that were actually founded
by individuals who pooled their
money, often paid an annual
or monthly fee to be
members of the library.
This is The Redwood Library
in Newport, Rhode Island,
the earliest surviving
building related
to a Society Library sometimes
called Athenaea [phonetic].
Sometimes they were in
basements of churches.
Other times they
did have buildings.
But these were put together,
as I say, by individuals.
Not just men, but women as well.
Women, as we move
into the 19th Century,
became the great
readers and reading clubs
and library clubs actually
formed the foundation
or the basis for many
of the public libraries
in the United States.
They were dissolved in the
collections given to the city
or the public library when
that became available.
And public libraries form
a major focus of the book.
As I say, we're just
skimming the surface here.
Here from a book recording the
reception of George Peabody
at The Peabody Institute
in 1856.
George Peabody was an
American financier in London,
actually a patron of Morgan as
well, who in 1852 gave $20,000
to his native village of
South Danvers in 1868,
renamed Peabody,
Massachusetts in his honor.
He arrived in 1856.
And all of the children
led him through the town
with processions and speeches,
and a great celebration.
This happened dozens
and dozens of times all
across the United States
in the 19th Century.
The public libraries
were very often endowed
by wealthy individuals who gave
money back to their communities
with mixed motives, I
suppose, but it did establish
by 1900 some 500
library buildings,
public library buildings
in the United States.
These grew in size.
Here the Peabody
Institute in Baltimore,
one of the great hall libraries
and one of the only ones
that survive actually.
Great cast-iron structure again
to be fireproof built in 1855.
There were others such as
The Boston Public Library,
the first one before
the one we know today,
which you can see here, which
was also a hall library.
These are primarily reference
libraries, academic libraries.
The books were fenced off.
The librarians would get them
for you, but you could read them
if you had the proper
introduction often
in the center of the room.
The Boston Public Library
has a whole other history,
however in the basement was
a public lending library
where it was decided that they
would lend books free of charge
to any citizen of Boston.
There was a lot of
debate about that,
whether they'd ever
see the books again,
whether they'd come back
filthy or with diseases.
There was even debate about
closing off the lending library
at one point because the workers
were all coming in unshowered
and quite odiferous, I
guess, smelly at the time.
Justin Windsor, the
long-time librarian,
the founding librarian
at The Boston Public Library
argued strongly against that.
He said put in a new ventilation
system, which they did,
and so it remained a
great public library.
The second library in Boston,
which you can see here,
of course marks the end of the
19th Century or the beginning
of what's often referred to
as The American Renaissance,
a new or neo-classical revival
that swept across the country.
Did you show the
reading room already?
Yeah, okay, that's fine.
You saw the reading room.
It actually was modeled
on the Bibliothec Juan
[foreign language] in Paris,
but you can see that even here
in the United States it became
even more sort of neo-classical
than this French library
of the mid 19th Century.
There were smaller
public libraries as well.
Henry Hobson Richardson,
out of Boston,
really created an important
prototype in part based
on the Bibliothec Juan
[foreign language].
I don't have a pointer, and
even if I did you can leave
that there for the moment.
You can see that the book
wing actually derives
and is an Americanized
kind of version
of the Bibliothec
[foreign language].
Book wings for storage areas,
up until this time they were
at the back of the building as
just rooms for storing books.
Richardson rotated it around
so you could identify this
as a library as well
a public library
with a grand kind of entryway.
Richardson was working in
the later 19th Century.
By the end of the century,
smaller libraries also.
Just an example of his impact,
and then the next one, I guess.
By the late 19th Century
and early 20th Century,
small libraries too
were taking on a neo-
classical kind of format.
This is a beautiful little
building in a very small town
in Massachusetts; in
Conway, Massachusetts
up in the northern
part of the state.
It's a great surprise to find it
at the end of the Main Street.
It was built by Marshall Field,
who was born in Conway and,
of course, moved to Chicago
and founded the great
department store empire.
And he gave this back
to the community.
It's by Shepley,
Rutan and Coolidge,
who were the successor
firm to Richardson.
But you can see how the
style shifted at this point.
And the plan itself
begins to take the form,
although it will become more and
more open in the 20th Century
of typical small public
libraries in the first decade
or two of the 19th Century with
the reading rooms to either side
of a central charging
desk or librarian's desk.
There were larger
libraries as well
that reflect this
new neo-classism,
but also the growing
importance of public libraries.
The Boston Public Libraries
have kicked things off,
but then of course we have the
great New York Public Library
by Carrere and Hastings designed
by its librarian,
John Shaw Billings.
Reading room covers actually
a quarter acre of space,
and was set atop
in the next slide.
You can see from the back, set
atop the stacks which had all
of the same kinds of
conveyor belts and tubes
and other things, but now
the books could just rise
up to the central delivery
area in the library.
But again I find it interesting
this faces, of course,
the park, Bryant Park.
But you can identify this
immediately as a library,
because you can recognize, if
you know what you're looking at,
the stacks that are an
integral part of the library.
In New York, it was joined
in the early 20th Century
by over 60 branch libraries
actually in around 1901.
Andrew Carnegie gave the
city 5.2 million dollars
to build 67 neighborhood
libraries,
which really became the
focus of his attention.
He wanted to educate the working
classes and Americanize them.
He had probably mixed
motives as well.
But the branch libraries were
a big part of his program,
but not of course the only part.
Everybody knows Carnegie
Libraries.
Oh, there's Mr. Carnegie.
And then the next, oh, which
marks the beginning really
of his library building program.
He began in 1886
to build buildings
in his steel mill towns.
Again as a giving
back to the community,
but also placating the
workers' homestead.
Some of you know perhaps
now because of the library,
but because of the strike,
a very violent strike.
This was built shortly
afterwards and it was intended
as a community center
that was an auditorium,
a swimming pool, a library.
And then the next, Marion the
Librarian would probably be
appalled, but a pool
hall as well,
which did not become a
regular part of his program.
As he began to offer
money for the construction
of public libraries to any
community in the United States
which would agree to fund
the library, the maintenance
of the library and
perpetuity at 10 percent
of the cost of the building.
So if he gave $10,000
for a building,
there had to be legislation
to make sure
that there was $1,000 a year to
buy books and to pay salaries,
and maintain the building.
Carnegie was a great
believer in self help.
He wasn't going to
give you everything.
He wrote an essay, a famous
essay in 1889 called Wealth,
in which he argued that you
could help but people had
to help themselves ultimately.
And they did, and they helped
themselves to his libraries,
I guess, Nebraska up there.
They spread all across.
>> Iowa?
>> Kenneth Breisch:
I'm sorry, yeah, Iowa.
That's one that should be there.
Spread all across the
country due to his largest.
Between 1889 and 1900, he
endowed 37 new library buildings
in the United States including
the old Washington Public
Library, which many of you
know, which I think is going
to resurrected finally, I hear.
And then by 1917, the
outbreak of the war,
when his program ended, he
had built 1,679 libraries
in the Unites States spreading
in large part this kind of neo-
classical style to
these small communities
where these buildings
really stood
out as monumental structures
within the community as symbols
of culture and learning as well.
So in some ways perhaps,
you know, Carnegie led.
His endowment led to things.
He didn't really
expect necessarily,
but it spread the public
library movement all
across the United States.
And through his personal
secretary,
modern library design.
James Bertram, in 1911,
who actually answered all
of the correspondence
from everybody
who asked for a library.
As I say, almost
1,700 were built.
There are dozens of reels
of microfilm at Columbia
of his correspondence
that survived.
It's actually quite
amusing sometimes.
He and Carnegie were
great believers along
with the librarian, Melville
Dewey, in spelling reform,
which you can perhaps
see on this slide.
But he published this short
pamphlet, in which he said
that these diagrams were
intended to be suggestive rather
than mandatory for communities
that wanted to build libraries.
Nowhere do they say they
should be classical,
but that was the style at the
time for a number of reasons
that we don't have
time to go into.
But ultimately his
goal was, as he says,
to obtain for the money the
utmost amount of effective,
and that's not a misspelling,
accommodation consistent
with good taste in building.
And his correspondence
follows that, that scheme.
But it introduced this
idea of the open plan
for the public library.
So that the librarian from the
central charging desk could keep
an eye on everybody in the
library as well as the books
at the rear of the building,
depending on the size.
Carnegie also endowed many
academic libraries including the
Tuskogee Institute Library,
which you see here designed
by the professor of architecture
there, Robinson Robert Taylor.
Here a view of Carnegie
with Booker T. Washington
and others celebrating
that particular library.
So academic libraries
are another story.
We saw the exterior
of the rotunda.
One of the ideas of
the book is to look
at the different configurations
and planning of libraries,
which you could get some
sense of tonight perhaps.
Here is a circular library,
which Jefferson designed
as a rotunda.
Or the first library at Harvard,
what was the largest library
in the country at the
time, Gorhall at Harvard,
which was designed to
hold 100,000 books.
The Boston Atheneum,
another private library,
was almost equivalent.
Josiah Quincy, the
president at the time,
for some reason celebrated this
and asked that it be designed
in the gothic style saying
that it was designed somewhat
in the form of the chapels
of many Catholic churches.
And I've never been
able to figure
out why Protestant
Harvard would be interested
in Catholic churches, but
you can see here an example
of a hall library
and the exterior.
It looks like a gothic church.
Academic libraries, of course,
led the way in terms
of expansion.
One of the largest earlier
libraries was The Sterling
Memorial Library at Yale.
James Gambell Rogers,
who designed many
other buildings there,
here you can see how
he displays the size
of the 5 million volume
collection this was intended
to hold in 16 tiers
of metal stacks,
which again are indicated on
the exterior by this great kind
of tower, I guess, to compete
with Harvard probably
in terms of size.
The section on libraries
ends with Frank Lloyd Wright,
who did design not just the
Guggenheim, but the Roux Library
at Florida Southern
College in Lakeland,
which you can see here
just before the war.
The reading room is fascinating.
The reading room
is the next there,
which again is centralized.
Actually perhaps even, although
Wright would deny it, I'm sure,
a kind of reflection of
Jefferson's library at Virginia,
although much more
organic and lyrical
than the classicism
of Jefferson.
Great drama, sweeping
curbs in the interior.
So that really kind of
covers the focus of the book.
There's an afterward.
I felt it necessary
to include some
of the late great masterpieces,
almost all photographed
again by Carol.
There's, of course, the
great Beinecke Library
to hold the Beinecke Collection
of Rare Books at Yale.
Louis Kahn's Phillips Exeter
Academy again look back
to the hall library
tradition, but with a great kind
of explication of the
structure of the building,
really incredible interior.
And then finally
we can end with one
of the recent again
masterpieces,
but a new experiment in
terms of library design.
The Seattle Public Library, by
Rem Koolhaas, which is designed
by a series of ramps
which sort of spiral
up in a rectangular way from
what he calls the living room
through a series of bookshelves
and computer spaces designed
to hold 1.4 million volumes.
It opens up looking out
over the City of Seattle,
especially from the tenth floor
where the reading
room is located.
Again really in the tradition
of The Boston Public Library
in some ways, but of
course in a very modern
and progressive kind of style.
So that's sort of it,
for a kind of overview.
If you have questions, I
don't know if we have time
for questions because
we have tours lined up.
Did I get through it?
[ Background Conversations ]
>> The whole library actually.
It's not so much
the whole library.
It's sort of later,
modern planning.
But, yeah, that would
be part of it.
The librarian could keep
an eye on everything.
But it was a style
that actually developed
in the early Renaissance period.
The Ambrosian Library
in Milan was one
of the first hall libraries.
I think it was just a
way of stacking the books
around the reading room, as much
as anything, and enclosing it.
And collections were
beginning to grow.
So they needed more space,
especially for The Ambrosian
Library, which was one
of the largest at the time.
But it became one of
the early typologies
for American Public
Libraries, which you can see
in the book after,
you know, 1860 or so.
Any other?
Yes, ma'am.
[ Background Conversations ]
In terms of form,
yes, to some extent.
But we were the great library
builders, really, I think.
The idea, and maybe this doesn't
quite answer your question.
But the idea of the public
lending library was invented
in the United States,
and it's one
of the great inventions along
maybe with National Parks
that we gave to the
world, I suppose.
European Libraries are
much more restrictive.
And, of course, in more
autocratic countries, you know,
the rulers didn't want people
reading books, you know.
So there wasn't a
proliferation of libraries.
There were academic libraries,
like the Bibliothec [foreign
language] for students.
They're even suspicious of that,
because the students
would take to the streets.
But for the most part,
collections were private
and so not on the same scale.
You know, there are
some exceptions,
but I think we really developed
this whole idea of the library
as really the centerpiece not
just of, you know, learning
and democracy, but of
culture and community
which is something I
didn't talk a lot about.
But it's kind of interesting
that public libraries
are returning
to the idea of the Athenaea.
They never really gave it up.
But these are places for
showing films, for story hour
for younger patrons,
but for lectures
and other community
kinds of events as well
as now computer access.
Any other?
>> How many of the libraries
have you seen personally?
>> Kenneth Breisch: Who?
Me? I don't know.
I lost count, lost
track long ago.
I've been doing this
for way too long.
It's just they all blend
together after a while,
maybe like mush in my head.
I don't know.
A lot. But as I say, there are
now, you know, almost 17,000
of these little guys around.
So I've a long way to
go, although I may turn
to other things one
of these days.
Is there another?
[Inaudible comment]
People are anxious
to see the gallery,
I think, as am I.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.